[Musique]
s'il est un lieu à La Réunion ou
l'histoire coloniale a définitivement
laissé son empreinte c'est bien ici dans
cet écrin de verdure niché sur les
hauteurs de Saint-Denis l'illette à
Guillaume isolée entre deux remparts cet
ancien pénitencier pour enfants du 19e
siècle témoigne encore aujourd'hui des
affres endurées par les jeunes détenus
un héritage du passé qui contraste avec
la beauté du paysage que le département
a souhaité honorer à travers un vaste
projet de préservation et de
valorisation du site un chantier qui se
termine en ce mois d'octobre 2022 grâce
au soutien de ses partenaires notamment
la mission patrimoine et la DAC Réunion
on a fait des travaux d'urgence
sur les maçonneries les endroits où
c'était susceptibles de garder quand
même les murs en l'état il faudrait il
fallait replacer les pierres comme ils
étaient auparavant et aussi non des étés
en bois comme vous voyez il y a moi pour
garder justement tout droit comme si il
n'est pas le retrouver d'ici quelques
années effondré on a été pilote sur
toute la partie travaux et financement
de cette opération les échanges ont été
très vifs et finalement assez assez
emprunt d'un sentiment de devoir
accompli puisque aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup échangé sur ce Capu être le
site jusqu'ici et finalement très très
satisfait de pouvoir remettre un petit
peu en évidence et sécuriser l'ensemble
des des travaux qui avaient été fait par
ses enfants sur ce site exceptionnel
initier il y a deux ans en octobre 2020
avec une étude à la fois historique
archéologique et archéobotanique menée
par l'INRAP ce chantier et le résultat
d'une volonté de reconnaître l'histoire
du pénitencier et de lui donner toute sa
place dans la mémoire collective sachant
que extraordinaire donc du coup il est à
Guillaume donc ça fait rappeler à une
histoire une histoire douloureuse pour
certaines familles parce que là des
enfants et bien c'est aussi les rendre
mémoire aujourd'hui à travers cet
engagement du département bien sûr le
loto du patrimoine a fait en sorte aussi
de pouvoir initier aussi une partie de
l'investissement et le département a
tout de suite pris le pas et c'est vrai
qu'on voit aujourd'hui le travail qui a
été fait par ces entreprises donc
travailler sur un site comme ça
nécessite bien sûr les logistique
particulier on voit aussi que là on
avait des tailleurs de pierre donc ce
sont des transmetteurs d'histoire aussi
c'est un savoir-faire qu'ils ont compris
aussi comment ces enfants et ses adultes
ont construit ce site et donc oui c'est
un lieu chargé d'histoire chargé
d'émotion et qu'il faut mettre en avant
qu'il faut faire connaître connaître à
toute la population réunionnaise qui
fait partie aussi cet engagement du
département est au quotidien a fait
rappel histoire à s'engager et à fait le
lien entre hier et aujourd'hui en
tradition et modernité je crois qu'il
faut faire connaître ce site les
vestiges de cet ancienne colonie
agricole pénitentiaire l'est imaginer
l'ampleur de la tâche des enfants sur
cette parcelle escarpée avec ses murs en
pierre sèche ces différents bassins sa
chapelle
ou encore son petit cimetière
donc il y a une première partie du
chantier qui s'achève aujourd'hui mais
évidemment le travail n'est pas fini
parce que il reste encore notamment ce
travail de diffusion de partage de la
mémoire de liliata Guillaume de façon à
ce que à la fois il est à Guillaume soit
mieux connu mieux compris mieux
approprié et
placer à sa juste place dans l'histoire
de la Réunion c'est à travers la
direction du lazaré donc j'assume que
nous portons les volets patrimonial et
culturels de ce projet donc un suivi qui
a consisté d'abord à contribuer à la
phase de diagnostic archéologique et
ensuite le suivi patrimonial et culturel
pour la partie travaux et nous avons
aussi pour
objectif de faire progresser la
recherche les connaissances par rapport
à l'histoire de l'Ilette allium comment
à fonctionner ce site avec un travail au
sein des Archives départementales et
aussi au sein des Archives nationales
d'outre-mer donc en métropole une fin de
chantier mais pas la fin de l'engagement
du département sur le site de l'illette
à Guillaume d'autres projets sont encore
à venir notamment pour créer un espace
d'interprétation et d'orientation des
visiteurs sur ce lieu chargé d'histoire
[Musique]